hey guys I've got big news my book is
finally ready for pre-order and this is
a game changer for men are you ready to
hear more about my book
here it is bold Pursuit it's a 90-day
devotional for men seeking the heart of
God here's the front cover for you on
the screen
and also the cover on the back
now I just wanted to mention that I have
a few gifts for you specifically for
those of you who are going to pre-order
the book and one of them is an exclusive
video where I share something deep about
my relationship with God something that
changed my life and that can change
yours as well
I was a Christian but I only came to
complete surrender with my dad my father
was about to die
he was abiding in Christ he fully
surrendered because he loved Jesus
Christ
you see you need to follow God in
everything you do to fully surrender to
him
this book is close to my heart and I
wrote it for men who are really seeking
the heart of God who want to grow in him
who want to abide in him have you fully
surrendered to Christ
or is there one or two things that
you're still holding back
are you a doer of the word and not just
the here
but as I said that video is only for
those who will pre-order the book and
to tell you more about the book what it
is all about
there's no better way than to read the
introduction to you so here we go
David asked God to create in me a clean
heart God and renew a steadfast Spirit
Within Me Psalm 51 verse 10 one of the
most famous men in the Bible who had an
unbelievable relationship with God was
David
he was a man after God's Own Heart
how many men who call themselves
Christians can say that today
how many men ask God the same request
that David asked how many men are really
serious about the relationship with God
how many men know God intimately
I believe that all of us men should have
this deep burning desire
to have a deep relationship with God the
way David did
David walked closely with God and we
still learn from his life today
thousands of years later
he had an Unstoppable desire to know the
God of all creation intimately not just
know about him
this 90-day devotional was created to
help us to deeply know God
each devotional is a guide to grow
closer to God and learn what it means to
truly abide in Christ
I believe thousands of Christian men
today are lukewarm and they do not
realize that God will spit them out of
his mouth
there's a big problem in the church
today
a problem of lukewarm men who care more
about living for the things of this
world than about living for the God of
this world
the gospel messages we hear in many
churches across the globe are often
Sensational superficial and
materialistic
we hear a watered-down gospel aimed at
tickling ears instead of transforming
lies and saving souls for Christ
I wrote this book to cut through all the
noise and bring back the sound doctrine
of scripture
I want to do so in Truth and Love
pointing men across the world to pick up
their cross and follow Jesus
to respect him to understand his
holiness
to seek him and his righteousness first
in everything they do
bold Pursuit calls us to radical
discipleship
which can only come from wholehearted
Devotion to Jesus Christ
I will turn to the Bible and teach
spiritual truths that will help us
understand what it means to truly abide
in Christ and to fully surrender to his
will for our lives
this is what we need in the church today
you cannot serve Christ with only your
heart or only your mind you need both in
other words you need to follow Christ
with the right Doctrine and devotion
you also need to know what it means to
follow Christ in the spirit and not in
the flesh
God has called me
to share the good news to the ends of
the world to all people and All Nations
to teach the word in season
and out of season
and to show people what it means to be a
reborn Christian
my heart for this book is that men
around the world
will come to understand
that the god of the past is the same God
of the present and the future
we can have a relationship with him like
David had
we can read and study his unchanging
truth in the Bible in the same way Godly
men did
men like John Wesley Charles Spurgeon
Jonathan Edwards D.L Moody Billy Graham
Andrew Murray and my father
Etienne maritz here in South Africa
bold Pursuit will change us to look in
the mirror to examine whether we are in
the faith and whether we follow Christ
with our whole heart mind and soul
this book will require a new and fresh
commitment to God and a burning desire
to please him in all that we do
most of us do not realize that God is
more eager to love us and answer our
prayers than we are to love him
and pray to him
God is always waiting
the god of the universe is always there
waiting for us
God is more eager to reveal himself to
us than we are to seek him
wow it is time we turn back to God fully
it's time we fall on our knees it's time
we return to the Bible
this devotional will guide you to do
just that
before you start with the first Daily
Devotional pray that God will bless you
and reveal himself to you as you
continue to work through the 90 days
read and work through each entry with
your Bible every day making it a daily
routine
you see this is especially good for
Ministries if you're a pastor preacher
and you have a Ministry if you want a
Bible study that men can work together
on this is it
there will be a few questions at the end
of every devotional and I want you to
answer them honestly and keep a notebook
close by to write down important notes
that you feel God wants you to focus on
finally be humble and open so that God
can change you according to his will
he is the Potter and you are the clay
there you go all the details are on the
website created for bold Pursuit
specifically
all the details are in the video
description down below if you want to
check it out if you're a man pre-order
it today if you're a woman do the same
thing because this is a perfect gift for
the men in your life and there are a lot
of men who need strong guidance
especially in the world that we live in
today
to become strong men standing firm in
their faith and who follows the example
set by Jesus in boldness truth love and
in the spirit and you can also read the
book yourself
and I want you to know that all the
money that we receive
from the book goes directly to our
ministry
it will help put bread on the table for
my team
who are working so hard behind the
scenes
and it will enable us to keep on sharing
the gospel to the ends of the world
so not only will the book help you to
grow spiritually closer to God but also
you'll be helping us in doing what God
wants us to do sharing the gospel to the
ends of the world
so thank you thank you for your support
and always remember that God loves you
and I love you too bye